oh god
oh it's like
immediate do you want another bite huh
yeah let's go this is really
spicy oh
[Music]
my hey guys on this episode of heat
eaters we are doing a deep dive someone
called The Noodle pleases hey guys guys
on this episode of heat eaters we're
doing a deep dive into what we're doing
a deep dive into one of my favorite
meals ever it's instant noodles and of
course you got to make it spicy this is
heat eaters everyone loves instant
noodles and has some sort of memory
attached to them there's just something
so satisfying and it's just delicious
first off I'm headed to the instant
Noodle Factory they have all different
types of instant noodles they have
topping you can make your own Combos and
later I'm meeting up with Joshua
Weissman at a test kitchen and we'll
taste all different types of instant
noodles and create our own ultimate
instant noodle hack let's head to the
first
[Music]
stop come on
guys we're here you guys it's the
instant Noodle Factory been hearing
about this place for a long time it
reminds me of being in Korea actually
you kind of go in and there's no staff
and it's like an honor System you put
cash down into a little bowl you grab
what you want and you like make your own
noodles and you know you you eat instant
Ramen it's such a big culture obviously
when you first walk in you see instantly
instantly the wall of instant noodles so
there's like a meat Seafood flavor
profile section then there's like a SP
spicy section which obviously we love
there's like premium there's vegetarian
you basically pick a base and then it
looks like on this wall you see the
topping and this is how you kind of
upgrade your noodles or Jazz it up so I
think I'm going to pick a few out of
this wall to take with me and then one
to eat here I definitely have to bring
different noodle types to Joshua so when
we're tasting we can get different
textures of noodles and also like
different types so we'll get get some
brothy we'll get some Saucy and
immediately here I I love these shapes
the scallion shishan pepper and also has
like that Mala which I think that is a
little bit uh different than a lot of
the noodles out there one of the most
popular ones right now is this bruda
carbonara one which is nice because it
has like a Cheesy element it's spicy but
it's also creamy and obviously I have to
bring one of the Ring of Fire so I think
I'm going to go with this one because it
looks insane it's called ghost pepper
and
obviously it's going to be spicy so and
I think for me I personally love a broy
Ramen so I'm looking at this one over
here the um the NTI the angry nugi I
feel like it's pretty spicy also it's
one of my favorite types of ramen and I
grow up eating it and then we'll kind of
jazz it up with different toppings all
right so I added spam corn Kim cheese
sliced jalapenos ghost pepper that's it
hi thank you so much okay enjoy thank
you okay so basically your noodles come
beautifully topped with
your toppings you're you put it directly
on the circle like so your tray comes
with a number and that's the number
you're supposed to press so one
one and that's it you wait and you stir
occasionally I need one of these
machines at home and obious OB L you
have like this toppings on the side and
you can either add it now or just eat it
on the side but I think I'm just going
to add it so it's supposed to be a
topping and that's the ghost
chili oh that's actually pretty spicy if
it's not it it actually smells spicy so
I'm just going to add half of it not all
of it cuz that's kind of a
lot oh God the ghost
pepper I don't know maybe I should
regret that decision of
I you getting flashbacks yeah okay so It
beeped let's do this thing
[Music]
see
M it's like Memories it's actually quite
spicy I think the jalapenos has added a
lot of
kick
[Music]
I made it
inedible I think the noodle itself was
spicy and then like I don't know what I
did to it oh my God that's
insane oh that's like real ghost
[Music]
pepper okay I'll eat a piece of
span spam is the
best actually the SP the saltiness of
spam helps subside some of that
heat oh
God I think this level should be like a
seven I don't know it's pretty
spicy so good also what's been recently
very trendy is like instant noodle hacks
one hack that I really love is using egg
yolk as the emulsifier so you kind of
like mix some of the broth with egg yolk
and make it super super creamy and
another one I love is to add like a lot
of flavor you can uh sautée scallions
and garlic before you make the instant
noodle so that gives it another
dimension of a body and flavor knowing
Joshua he's going to really want to Jazz
it up and make it fancy so you know I'm
down for it but in the
meantime I'm going to finish this
bowl this spam is really good a it I
love spam
oh thank you so much there you go thank
you for
coming so we are in The Test Kitchen you
know we got all fancy here today and
this is a nice Studio I wish my
apartment look like this hello what's up
I'm here to ruin my life let's
go does that mean that you can't handle
spicy food I can handle spicy food but I
know that we're doing some stuff that's
beyond that you know I mean might just
be my conscience I've done videos where
I've made other people eat spicy things
that are unnaturally spicy this is
payback thanks for joining me thank you
for having me I'm so excited we're going
to eat some really spicy noodles if you
had to kind of um break it down like
what are you looking for to me it needs
to have certain level of spice it needs
to have good shoe I hate I hate goopy
puree like noodles what makes a superior
dish over you know good dish is texture
yes it is according to your new book
it's true it is everything it really
is and uh it's got to be salty you got
to have that Umami I hope it has MSG in
it MSG is a very important critical part
in any type of noodle dish I think okay
so let's go through it I'm going to go
bring I'll be sure rub my eyes after
this you'll be okay so
good sorry I'm unhinged right now so the
first one is the noodles um scallion
chishan pepper love it it's such a
interactive spice I feel like yeah I
like that word interactive spice yeah it
Mak sure her whole body kind of tingle
yeah these are the kind of noodles that
I personally really like these pick up
sauce very well smells so good see how
much these noodles want to cling to each
other that's what they're doing with the
sauce I don't know if you guys you guys
can't see this but this says bre breathe
on it holy what are we about to do
here we go
cheers
great texture on the noodles because the
noodles are bigger I think the sauce
naturally just coats your palette more
you know buts more chesan Capricorn it
needs more Mala you need to have that
body ele like the body feels you're just
like uh-huh uh-huh next one this just
looks spicy I don't I don't even need to
read ghost pepper on here to know that
this is made to you up yeah I mean
first of all it's a black and red that's
like the hometown colors of like every
super villain so the noodle itself I
think are are black oh really yeah oh
like like Squid Ink oh wow yeah did you
just cut yourself I just cut myself on
the packaging see see I told you super
villain I told you do we have a do we
have a napkin in here medic oh my God
you really clutch that's a good one all
these like demonic Vibes it attacked you
but it attacked me in a positive note
you do get this little
Fork cheers there cheers
okay why are these so hard to grab you
definitely get it like right away right
mhm the broth that's where it's at the
more you eat it the spicier it gets yeah
I feel it in the broth actually yeah
it's spicy it's at a spice level where
you're kind of like I don't really want
this That's Where It's At what is it
it's ghost pepper right yeah it's
building that's what it is Ghost Pepper
makes you like get mucousy in your mouth
when you trying to breathe you suffocate
yourself that's why it's called a ghost
pepper this one's spicy because your
your soul is going to leave your
body
and of course this one is probably your
most popular one on the market at the
moment when it comes to spicy noodles um
it's the Pura Ramen they have different
varieties this one happens to be the
carbonara one I also love The Branding
though like look at this cute chicken
it's also also a carbonara powder never
heard of that and Carbonara sauce so not
carbonara but yes I still think that
it's going to be one of the spicier ones
really it is kind of lowkey baby BR they
really don't care they're just like yeah
it's mild give this to your
baby all right all right Cheers
Cheers it's like the fake taste right
the fake cheese taste but it is spicy
yeah that's not mild and it's pink it's
so cute and then lure the babies what
are you thinking what are some inspo my
favorite sauce texture I know I talked
about it was the carbonara one okay
I almost want like a combination flavor
wise so okay sauce texture from the
carbonara M flavor of the scallion a
creamy Mala and spicy maybe we should
redo the carbonara we're going to fix it
cuz it could have been good and it had
nice heat we like the spice
lle okay here we are we have our setup
yes for our homemade instant noodle
party love it I think the first thing we
do is pick our noodles I feel like I
already know which noodle you're going
to pick just point that yeah I mean we
we all know that you're obsessed with
this I'm going to make a little spice
packet okay and I have an array of spicy
I like using a lot of different Chili
Peppers guaru guaru it's like
beautifully sweet spicy Perfect Balance
I have some smoked paprika cuz I feel
like smokiness will be kind of be nice
and then of course the Trinidad Scorpion
pepper from smoking EDS farm and I oh
yeah oh yeah right wow that's crazy it's
crazy I just
know garlic powder onion powder white
pepper I I like white pepper over black
so good sugar salt and then of course
like the MSG but this is the beef
flavored MSG right I mean it's just
going to make everything taste good
that's my SP special spice blend I love
it looks beautiful it really does look
exactly like what you would see in a
Ramen packet and then now you're going
to go in with the oil yes so I love
chili oil I make it all the time it's
just as simple as this right you put
things in a bowl and there's only one
extra step you pour a little hot oil on
it that's it so spices and then hot oil
spices and then hot oil that's going to
flavor the whole sauce this is just
going to kind of coat a little bit of
viscosity a little bit of texture to it
a little bit of greasiness but in a good
way we have fried shallots BR garu you
know what since we're on the chili
powder we have this since yours is a
little lighter I think I should go
heavier it is a chili oil fine I mean it
is being so we'll just put a little bit
bloomed with the oil a little bit do you
think the the oil did you just add the
whole thing that was like a tablespoon
was not supposed to do that oopsie some
sesame seeds sliced fresh garlic green
onion sugar so Sichuan pepper corns for
you know we wanted a little bit more of
that numbing spice all right so I'm
going to add all of these woo we've got
MSG smell that so now I'm going to add
my liquid ingredients this is going to
help break that down a little bit before
we add our oil so we've got a little bit
of Chinese black vinegar dark so
so this is going to just give a little
bit more of an aged depth of flavor a
little bit of viscosity to it and then
regular soy just for to continue up the
Umami and a little bit of extra salt
it's stirred you're going to make sort
of a little bit of a thick paste oh that
smells up can I can I smell it
that's not going to be
good damn the combo of the chesan with
the Trinidad Scorpion pepper is insane
now it's ready to receive our hot oil
which is very very hot all right look
like that I love that when I just it's
so beautiful it's so nice so you want to
stir it while it's still frying so that
it you get you give every little spice
every granual a chance to get pocked
that's beautiful that's our chili oil
topping it's going to provide a little
bit of texture but it's also going to
provide a lot of heat all right I think
this is like a beautiful you know combo
got our dry we got our
wet deceptive so we have our noodles
those are going to go in 5 minutes we
cooked down some Guan Al here right
whenever you cook quanal you cook it
down low heat get it crispy get that fat
rendered you've got that happening here
so at this point um we can go ahead and
add our sliced garlic a little extra
garlic flavor and some sliced Thai Chili
that's right more spice but this is
fresh spice you were talking about that
earlier yeah I feel like it's a nice
different dimension when you use fresh
chilies versus dried I think we make our
little paste of egg yolk so we're going
to take our yolks out and then your
spice mix add about half cup of your
pearo and then we're just going to mix
all this up beautiful a nice beautiful
paste this is the base of our Emulsion
okay so like when we add our noodles the
noodle
water this is going to mulfy with that
it's going to create a nice glossy sauce
you can already see how thick this is I
this is like I love that that's going to
be nice so we have our noodles they are
nice and hot the water is a little
starchy which means it's going to
emulsify this beautifully so I'm adding
my fried garlic fried chilies the Guan
chal
beautiful okay and then we're ready for
for you to come in dollop of our
beautiful egg yolk Emulsion yes so I'm
going to get this started a little bit
get these uh these eggs heated up a
little bit before I add our liquid
halfway all stir that in
yeah M just to make sure it salt levels
are good wow wow spice
spicy we didn't even have the chili o
yet no I'm kidding it's not that bad
okay we have a beauty Bowl we do have a
beauty Bowl which is come on
oh come on just for you naturally
naturally of course so that'll go in
beautiful beautiful beautiful chili oil
all right and just layer that around
nicely and then and then the oil part
the
oil which can go right on and then you
add your fresh parmesan Rano cre it
right on top look at that it's like the
perfect Asian Italian yeah it's weird
how well they go hand in hand when you
match
ready to taste I'm ready all right so
this is like a classic Korean move you
eat it with on the lid Ah that's
beautiful that's I love it all right
here we go cheers okay
[Music]
cheers come on you got
this it's like immediate oh
[Music]
no that's why I laughed I was like want
them oh that's
F fine it's really delicious it's
just the numbing spice is a lot it's so
delicious though I'm fine I'm
fine do you want another bite huh
yeah I mean it's I love another bite
super super delicious just maybe add a
little less of the chili oil the mix of
the egg yolk emotion and the cheese
makes
it not that bad oh
[Music]
God all right yeah you got to put the
noise cancelling on for this I mean
I think it depends on the bite like
that's the thing I definitely bit
straight into one of those
Trinidad and then it fell in the back of
my throat can you imagine imine eating
this cool bowl no like we're eating one
bite toilet's going to look like that
afterwards all right bill you got to try
it yeah come on Bill come on Bill woo
bill I love it bill got it actually it's
like really delicious now you'll notice
that they have toilet paper over in the
corner why is that that's that's for
me so like to eat an entire oh my god oh
my god dude somebody get this guy where
where's OSHA call OSHA what looks so
good when he eats it yeah right yum he's
a good you're a good noodle slurper oh
my God your mouth is going to be on fire
it's all over his mouth you guys I got
you you're s at this thank you no you
actually just dabbed it all over his
beard it's pretty good it's pretty good
it's not bad it's good I feel like it's
so numb now that it's more enjoyable
that I you know I can't really feel
anything okay you can't feel anything
but you can taste it I'm sweating yeah I
can't feel anything
either I'd buy it uh you buy it a cold
winter night you you open one of these
you know wow it has a really addictive
quality like that's delicious yeah the
addiction is me calling
911 well I got something special for you
oh Jesus let's
go the heat eater spicy noodles of
Joshua Weissman and as
Choy you're welcome to hell
oh you going to R it right to the
hospital bedroom you know what it's
super delicious I mean very very very
spicy I would say the noodle texture
perfect we got the creaminess that you
wanted and we only had to add a few
ingredients and once you make like this
chili oil or the chili blend yeah you
can kind of really make your own
noals it's the gift that keeps on giv
you know you can put this on anything
and make it awful I mean I mean make it
delicious well Joshua thank you so so
much for doing this thank you for having
fun I think we created something awesome
I do I think I I think we created
something very special that exists
nowhere else in my opinion just as good
if not better than the instant ramens
that we had today what do you mean it's
way better way better so Joshua talk to
me what are you doing lately what do you
got going on aside from these spicy
noodles I'm going to do my best okay I'm
going to fight my way through this but
my new
cookbook sorry I can't see um texture
over taste is out today well it came out
today it's definitely out by the time
you've watched this it's available
everywhere books are sold you know just
like we talked about earlier texture is
important the reason why these noodles
are so good The Chew the slurping
quality the viscosity of the sauce
that's what this book is about it
focuses on that but these are recipes
anybody can make and more importantly it
will make you a better
eater thank you for having me appreciate
it we did it we did a great
job no when you you it literally scared
me did you see that I was
like go Replay that clip and it's
literally me like
[Music]
fck hey look now it has like an extra
flare a spicy it's personalized oh it's
pequ we could sell this we could sell
this as a special copy ooh I wish I
could sell that the FDA would not like
that well we have to have a disclaimer
on it possibly have people assigned
waivers when they buy it agree right big
agree hey guys it's Esther from heat
eaters thanks for watching please like
And subscribe and for more episodes
click here